- I predict pain, tears.
- Chili chips are not
big at all in Australia,
I'd say.
- We don't really have
the extreme flavors.
- I think it's gonna be easy.
I think I'm gonna smash it.
(rock music)
- Ah, yeah, I was gonna
say it's not very hot,
and then it goes down and it is quite hot.
- Oh, there it is.
- I hate chili and that wasn't even bad,
that's very mild.
- It tastes like chili and
lemon lollies or something.
- Yeah, like chili and
lemon washing-up detergent.
(rock music)
- [Voiceover] Tastes like a Dorito.
- Like a stale Dorito.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, I like that.
- That was good, it was too small.
- It's like one of those where you just
want to fill your whole mouth with,
and go crazy with, like a Pringle.
- Yeah, I can see myself stuffing
big fistfuls of that into my face.
- Not spicy.
- Not much chili flavor.
- No chili flavor.
(rock music)
- Tastes like a 99 cent
burrito from Taco Bell,
and I love it.
- They kind of hurt me.
- That's definitely spicy.
- That tastes like my
mouth after a night out.
- Can't stop eating them.
(rock music)
- Woah, that doesn't look like the
color of something that
should go in your mouth.
- No.
- I don't even think that color exists.
- It's built to nothing.
- Like air wrapped in flavor red.
- It's like a bad Twistie.
A Twistie that lost its way.
- It's burning the back of my mouth
at the moment, and that was one.
- Mm.
- So I'm not going in for a handful.
(rock music)
- [Voiceover] (laughs) What is this?
- This looks like a little
bit of rolled-up meat.
- That looks like a salami stick.
- Pure chili.
- You should not put more than
one of these into you.
- Mm-mm.
- No.
- I think it would be great with a beer.
- Tastes like off, hot, chili cheese.
- Probably the perfect amount of chili.
- Feel like I've just been
punched in the throat.
(rock music)
- [Voiceover] They're
kind of a smoky chili,
or no chili, just smoky.
- It's like a barbecue
flavor style, but then
now the heat is coming and again,
my mouth's on fire.
- It tastes really bacony.
- Yeah.
- It's like a cheese and bacon bowl
but quite subtle.
(rock music)
- [Voiceover] Funyuns,
I've heard about Funyuns!
- [Voiceover] So have I!
- [Voiceover] That'd be
good with sour cream.
- Yeah, or guac.
- I like the texture,
it was soft and fluffy.
- They taste like nothing, but crunch.
- It really is a Funyun.
(rock music)
- I think these ones they certainly
look a lot scarier than they taste.
- I'm supportive of chili flavored chips.
I think we need more of them here.
Australia hasn't embraced
the chili chip yet.
But we should.